[Musique]
on
ge a voulu bien crier le nom de certains
joueurs mais on en a on n'a pas eu accès
là on a on a pas été permis d'aller un
peu plus proche d'eux mais quand même de
loin on a vu l'entraînement ils sont en
forme je crois à cette équipe et je suis
sûr que ces gars là est mono produit du
beau spectacle et qu'ils vont garder
c'est est ce que ce qu'on fait au
cameroun
bon
[Musique]
j'ai fait le test rapide antigénique
pour aller voir le match d'ouverture
j'ai la voiture là avec tous les
drapeaux dessus doyen et
j'attends que j'attends poil est à la
fois les supporter le cameroun perd
[Musique]
on a eu plus plus nombreux qu'on
attendait quoi
en savoie le court surtout quand c'est
ton équipe on étudiait les lions on veut
se porter notre viande on obligeait la
tempe je n'ai pas encore le biais c'est
un peu compliqué mais bon voilà
mais je crois que je vais trouver d'ici
avant demain
[Musique]
dans la note rédigée ici à la nôtre bien
franchement pour camérounais j'aime au
cameroun il mais on va devenir des héros
[Musique]